الخبراء بالتفجير النووي واخرون توقعوا
بان تهدد امن الغذاء العالمي وفيما وصفته
اوكرانيا بجريمه حرب اعتبرته روسيا عملا
ارهابيا فما اهميته الاستراتيجيه وما حجم
الضرر الناتج
هذا السد بني عام
1956 على بعد 30 كيلومترا من مدينه خرسون
الاوكرانيه وتحديدا في الاجزاء التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا يبلغ ارتفاعه 30 مترا وطوله
ثلاثه كيلومترات ومئتين متر ويحتوي على 18
كم مكعبا من المياه تقريبا كان السد هدفا
محتملا للضربات منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه نظرا لضرر الكبير الذي سيحدثه
تدويره فمياه السد تساعد في تشغيل محطه
كخوفكا للطاقه الكهرومائيه وتضرره ينظر
بازمه طاقه في اوكرانيا كما ان نقص منسوب
المياه سيؤدي لجفاف الحقول في جنوب
اوكرانيا وخلال اربعه ايام ستغمر المياه
المنطقه المجاوره وكاله تاسر روسيا صرحت
ان السدس استهدف بواسطه صاروخ من قاذفه
صواريخ اولخا الاوكرانيه اثناء قصفها على
خرسون فيما اكد الجانب الاوكراني بان
الجيش الروسي هو المتسبب بالتفجير شاركونا
من هو المسؤول عن هذا التفجير وما هدفه